Severe economic sanctions on Putin
and all those folks around him
choking off access to technology
as well as cutting off access to
the global financial system
has had a profound impact already.
In response to the brutal,
unprovoked and illegal invasion of
Ukraine, the U.S., the UK
and countries in the European Union
have effectively cut Russia out
of the global financial system.
Germany suspended construction of
the Nord Stream 2 natural gas
pipeline and is talking about
beefing up its military.
Italy and France are seizing yachts
and other assets of Russian citizens
on the grounds that their
kleptocrats profiting from an
outlaw regime.
The US Congress is contemplating a
bill that would let the government
grab Russian assets in America
above $5 million and use
the proceeds to aid Ukraine.
A slew of private companies have
also voluntarily withdrawn from
Russia. Apple and Google Pay have
stopped working on the Moscow Metro.
Russian filmmakers with ties to
the government have been disinvited
from showing their work abroad.
The International Cat Federation
has banned Russian felines
from competition.
Such actions are, of course,
understandable in the face of
unjustifiable aggression.
But will they actually work to
facilitate Russia's withdrawal
from Ukraine or weaken
Vladimir Putin's regime?
If history is any guide, the simple
answer is no.
And not only that, they will mostly
harm the already long suffering
people of Russia and quite possibly
be used to justify even more
egregious behavior on the part
of Putin.
Historically, sanctions, especially
in authoritarian regimes, often
galvanize the targeted countries.
For instance, US economic sanctions
on imperial Japan before World War
Two were taken as an act of war
and encouraged more repression at
home and expansion abroad.
In October 2019, Government
Accountability Office report found
that sanctions often have unintended
consequences, including negative
impacts on human rights or public
health. Sanctions against Cuba,
Iran and Venezuela haven't had
the desired effects of regime change
and liberalization.
In fact, they've served as a
scapegoat for bad economic
and police state policies.
Sanctions don't work because there's
almost always workarounds, notes
Johns Hopkins economist Steve
Hankey. That's especially true in
the current case, with China and
India largely abstaining from the
Western response.
And why punish regular citizens
in autocratic regimes for the crimes
of their unelected leaders?
Everyday Russians, thousands of
whom have been imprisoned for
protesting, are also victims
of Putin's madness.
Private companies opting to withdraw
from Russia voluntarily is
less objectionable than government
mandated sanctions.
But it's also not clear what
they accomplish other than stoking
jingoism and punishing innocent
people. Backing Putin into
a corner politically isn't going
to lead him to retreat.
Rather than doubling down on
sanctions and promising ever more
draconian measures, the Biden
administration should be developing
off ramps or ways to de-escalate
the conflict by giving Putin some
sort of face saving measure to
withdraw or abide by a settlement
that gives maximum peace and safety
to Ukraine and stability to Europe
and the rest of the world.
In all likelihood, there is no
perfect solution.
But as our experience of the past 20
years should remind us, foreign
policy is ultimately not a game
of good triumphing over evil
or idealism winning out over
realism.
It's about making the world a better
place, not a perfect
place.